I had parents who believed in me I made
sure I went to school walking a long
distance and it has always been about
challenging myself to go forward so I
was really excited to be a student so
fast forward I had to work hard to get
to University and I've been a student
all all my life because even when when I
work I continued being a student I still
you know go of so my activism was is
really intertwined because looking at
how it all began when I got into the
field of human trafficking it is a new
Gander it's in America it's in your
backyard it may it make manifest itself
in different ways as I was growing up it
had you know for me I was I was
confronted by the Lord's Resistance I
mean years of children in armed conflict
I have done staged some stage tours I
have Dennis tattoo of Colorado you know
New Jersey and I went to Las Vegas and
wherever I've gone obscene one of the
biggest problems you know in America is
runaway children you know there's that
age where traffickers know that they
rely on that vulnerability you know that
age when you know when teens think that
their parents are not so cool and they
run away from home so there's always
somebody you know children to grab them
and take them through a different a
different path
there's trafficking in in in agriculture
in this in this country among even
immigrant you know populations but also
among the locals themselves actually
exploitation
you know from city to city of come
across are victims of trafficking whom
I've spoken to have spoken in various
audiences and after I've spoken I've
seen these girls especially you know
come to me and confiding to me what
happened to them in the a situation so
it's everywhere we just have to pay
attention we have to learn
and empower ourselves with knowledge in
my country Uganda we have like I said
the use of children armed conflict we
have sexual exploitation we have forced
labor a use of you know children for
street begging
we have remove of organs you know that
the tread in human in human organs we
have even the remove of organs for
rituals and exploitation where you know
somebody to construct a building like
this you know the witch doctor tells you
know you have to kill somebody and spill
some blood so that you can become rich
people believe in things like that so
those things are real and they happen
around the world we just have to pay
attention and see how we can be involved
when I got the opportunity to attend the
Clinton Global Initiative and meant that
commitment of action to counter human
trafficking I knew I needed to build a
rehabilitation center for survivors of
human trafficking I knew I wanted to
take books so that you know children can
have an education and they remember then
thinking okay how am I going to do this
because I had really huge goals I wanted
to build that Center I said I was going
to Train law enforcement and I started
off I was going to train 1,000 law
enforcement and I was a student and I
knew you know to Train law enforcement
or to take books and to create a
rehabilitation center I had to be
creative because he is a student who
comes from Africa you're in America you
don't have any money to implement those
huge projects but in my university what
I found out quickly was that there was a
lot of food at the university so you'd
go for student events and many times the
food just goes to us I said okay this is
an opportunity for me to serve money so
I started saving money which I would
have used by food and I used to eat food
from school events and of course you
know you can take take away and I said
$1,000 and so with $1000 I went to books
for Africa
who are best in Minnesota st. Paul say I
went to them I said listen I want to
take a container of books to Uganda
that's 23,000 books that's how I started
and I had never done fundraising before
but thank goodness when we are the
Clinton Global Initiative they taught us
you know how to raise money for your
commitment so if I knew it I raised
money to take a container of books and
one of the happiest happiest moments in
my life is you know going through the
border between Uganda and Kenya and
being in this truck huge truck I bet
that's for the 40 feet full of books and
navigating through the rods and
eventually by the time I came to this
village school the kids being just so
excited so the excitement of seeing
children lifting boxes and carrying them
to their classroom every kid like having
a book you know to own a book
and flipping through the pictures
mathematics made easy so that was really
an exciting moment for me that's when I
realized wow I can actually do this and
and and so that's how I approached even
my other you know commitments one thing
you know at a time and just being
creative along that way you know find
out what is happening in your community
you know find out which which
organizations are dealing with with with
with the problem and and I'm actually
also find out on how you can help
because believe it or not all of us have
a stake in this I keep telling people if
you have a big mark like I do yeah you
learn about it and then you talk about
it
some people have money those support
organizations which are doing this work
you know sometimes just about learning
you tell your neighbor are be mindful if
you see something you know wrong you
know somewhere you know you talk to
their you know to the police and let the
authorities know so trafficking exists
it exists everywhere and we just have to
be united in action because traffickers
are so organized very organized
so they they have their operations
within countries but they also cross
borders and when they cross borders
that's when we need to really you know
collaborate you know internally in
collaborate you know law enforcement so
sharks everybody is important but also
internationally to know how their
because there's a lot of money you know
to be made within you know trafficking
of human beings so to really pay
attention on what is happening in your
community and what how trafficking in
manifests itself and to know that
whichever problem we have like human
trafficking there's always help I'm also
speaking to survivors out there because
I work with them a lot and they go
through really so many challenges that's
the reason I even decided to build a
Center for survivors of human
trafficking because I know that they
need rehabilitation they have rights
they need people to pay attention you
know to them and to really listen to
what they need you know as they go
through life to make a better life for
themselves
I remember one victim especially whom I
took to my house because I didn't have
anywhere to take her and she was
circumcised and forced to marry someone
even before she healed and when she flee
from her husband's home her parents did
want to take her back they call her
names they said she just jumped the
family and I remember how calling me at
midnight and me picking her up from
where she had run to bring to my house
and after three days you know she
disappeared and I never seen hi again
just because I do not have
rehabilitation
to take her so pay attention to
survivors
[Music]